[Music]
chloe bailey graced the vma stage with
her debut performance as a solo artist
performing her new single have mercy
[Music]
chloe wore an all pink bodysuit very
reminiscent of her mentor beyonce's
bootylicious look
[Applause]
she also gave us this moment where she
put the mic down and allowed her moves
to speak for themselves
her sister hallie bailey might not have
been on stage with her but she was still
there for the big moment introducing her
sister's solo artist debut at the vmas
this year
she has stepped into her own artistry
sharing a message of self-expression and
self-love and i am so so so proud of her
i love you sis we spoke to chloe about
it all on the red carpet yeah well i'm
very pumped i'm so happy with the
response of that mercy i just put it out
two days ago in the music video and
tonight i get to bring it to life with
my performance and it's going to be
really special
[Music]
oh so good so good okay what is the deal
with the spoon honey oh yes well it's a
part of the dress darling it's mommy
darling it's fashion oh fashion giving
us fashion family i'll be seeing you at
the med gala tomorrow night yes you will
see my sister and i will be there i
missed your sister are you is she pumped
to be watching you perform tonight she
is and she's presenting me as well so we
still get to be together
[Music]
you